and welcome to this video about the
sixth round of the chess olympiad in
istanbul this is a bit late because I
was traveling back from my yeah vacation
place back home so I'm back home with my
usual equipment but this is why this
video about a game that has been played
on Monday it's only on Wednesdays own
needed a two to catch up here yeah six
round was played down as mentioned two
days ago on Monday and it's all a big
clash of the favorites between Russia
and Armenia and the Sun as of course
very much on important for the further
cause of the tournament if this match
had a winner in fact that ended in a tie
to 22 against you and we had two draws
played on both three and four and SEGA
movsisyan beat Alex on the Grisha gonna
very complicated game and on board one
we had bloody makram nick playing
against Levon Aronian which is also the
game i'll be featuring here simply
because of its um yeah sport yeah pure
Borden's and terminals standings but
also because it was an interesting game
in the other matches we had a
hard-fought 22 or firm united states
against germany four drawers and i think
it's very you have very correct match it
looked like that at no point any player
would have had a decisive advantage
which has been spoiled or anything it
was pretty much within the drawing
margin um other bidjan bit croatia 31
very convincingly with raja baath and
Mama dro of scoring um yes bein be dumb
the Czech Republic two and a half one
and a half and in an upset the
Philippines betta Bulgaria two and a
half to one and a half with three
drawers and when Master babosa beating a
keyring your gif pretty much win of an
outsider slide outside at least
and also it must be said that gr EF was
clearly winning but spoiled it me at the
end from winning to losing position so
I'm the interesting round but that's a
look at the the game here between
Kramnik and aronian we start off with
one d4s expected and we have for the
sloth defense kremmling plays Knight c3
and our own Leonid f6 all the non moves
and now you would expect them yeah
mostly 9003 are maybe III from kramnik
leading to a moran line here on possibly
am also if you would play sharper this
the the semi Slav probably followed by
age six this has been debated in their
matching i think it was april this year
this kind of line they played in Game
one where kramnik actually suffered one
of his very rare losses with wide but in
this game Kramnik played the exchange
variation um which has which is very
rarely played at top level or grandmas
allowed simply because it is thought to
be a bit too harmless but then the
positive side of this line certainly
especially in a team event is that it is
super safe white can really am play for
some very very little pool without any
risk so it's not a bad choice for 14
team match loss with white for instance
on board one is pretty much a disaster
ya know Bishop f4 it must be said that
the exchange variation um has some finer
points to it for instance in this kind
of move over white place the early
Bishop f4 it is a bit different to to
playing this kind of exchange variation
where all nights are already developed
we can see that in the game
you should form this night stays back on
g1 and this is really a difference
because sometimes 92 comes into
consideration yeah white rice with this
move order to have some more options but
it also offers black additional
possibilities in this position black for
example has the very interesting move
Queen to b6 which is a very good idea to
play if you want to yes they have a bit
of trouble as black as you simply attack
this pawn and also put a bit of pressure
on the d4 pawn in fact all moves let
that cover the pawn a bit meek I mean
you don't want to put the Queen on d too
it's simply not such a great square and
how else would you put you would you
cover it this says has two possible
problems one is this but this is
interesting for white maybe even but
also black code could take and damage
your pawn structure and it's not so even
anymore it offers like some ideas to
play for one in fact them the best move
he has his rook c1 and black and in fact
snatch this pawn and it leads to quite
complicated unclear position but the
rohingya didn't play this just played 96
and yeah States solid III now and in
this position black can play moves that
lead to to the main lines where wide
place 9003 later I can play some
independent option than fact and Aronian
decided from a sixth of this position
but black he also has other ideas he
could play on besides Queen b6 and stir
possible he could also play this move or
just interesting which in fact I played
myself on a couple of times when i add
this position it simply well yeah it
takes the Queen and wide would need to
make moves that he
not necessarily wants to make and it is
very important to know that move like 93
years very toothless as black am very
much enjoys this exchange he wants to
exchange this night and gets rid of his
somewhat problematic bishop in general
nights are better in this kind of
position than bishop so want to get rid
of this piece on idea three isn't a good
move really what white needs to play as
either this one or more enterprisingly
f3 attacking this bishop and if black
would go here you can even consider
gaining more space with reform which
leads to quite interesting positions
it's not really draw um like and also
just drop back to the seven which what I
usually played and I'll just claim that
this is a weakness but he also wife can
play stuff like g-form and you see that
the exchange is not always about
exchanging all the pieces and making a
draw this is quite interesting okay but
they're only unplayed to move a six
which is also rather popular it's a bit
of a waiting move black simply once why
to plain idea three and then play Bishop
g4 and equalize but of course why
doesn't do this you place push-up g3 and
yeah now what should like do we cannot
play this natural move simply hangs um
of course I need to mention like and
also simply play the symmetrical stuff
it's the dullest of all but you can do
it okay so a six Bishop d3 i'm here like
also has more than one one option aronia
actually played a somewhat somewhat
lesser known line we played here g6
which is a rather uncommon
in this kind of structure because the
fianchetto is very often not such a
great idea on the main move probably is
still Bishop g4 which is somewhat
similar to the earlier Bishop g4 that i
just showed like and also fall back to
this plan and just play we should be
sampling castles and so on which is
slightly passive but still playable it's
not so terrible with this bishop so not
so active course but it's so it's
playable you only play g6 and the idea
is obviously you can see this Kramnik
now played h3 this is designed again
against this idea so oops this was a bit
too good h3 is just to prevent this
Bishop g4 idea and now aronian played
Bishop f5 this was obviously the idea of
g6 to support this Bishop f5 move and he
had very much expected kramnik to take
on f5 which she didn't do surprisingly
um it's not that I think it's terrible
from like that I thought of expected him
to take here to somewhat we can like
spawn structure but it's not we're very
weak extra porn cannot really claim that
but um it would have been simply a
different pawn structure he didn't care
much though about this idea he just
continued Knight f3 and yeah black
exchanged and played Bishop g7 their
white castles black castles all very
very normal moves and now rook f 2 c1
white wants to play on the cfl obviously
this is the only open file and you also
take the F rope because possibly this
rook is useful on a one while they work
on f1 never has any decent idea on e 1
or d1 FC one is so normal yeah and how
to assess this position obviously it is
quite symmetrical but one very important
difference is that black has got this
fianchetto bishop
which is biting on this default born and
doing nothing and this Bishop actually
has some ideas probably possibly
supporting something on c7 avoiding
rugby eight moves Quincy seven moves so
this Bishop is exerting slight pressure
while this Bishop g7 is not doing so
much and the other a slight problem that
black has is this pawn structure think I
need to get rid of most of this year
this pawn structure this lets a slight
problem because it has weakened the dark
squares so night coming to c5 we also
see that like now plaguey 694 we see now
that this night on c5 is the possible
nuisance attacking this pawns and this
is why this bone structure sometimes a
slight problem by the way e 6 is a move
that you could also questioned if you
look at it as first because it would it
weakens the dark squares even more but
then it's a it's a good moves little
because of the plan that like employs in
the game he was to reroute the bishop to
have eight and get it possibly exchange
so e6 prepares this 94 also good why not
occupy the center and our prom Nick 19
to see five so we had this exchange
which um yeah just sped up white some
yeah wide stumbling on the sea far
widest quicker on the sea foam it's
still very solid for black but still the
sea far is something my black played
27th certainly useful connecting the
rocks look to see one look F to see
agent looks very logical and still quite
harmless hope like a six now a three
sorry yeah this is to prevent any kind
of ideas like this and also of course to
prepare be form to support the queenside
expansion yeah black plate Bishop f8 as
mentioned this was the idea of the six
move ya retreat to see two and now the
move ff6 this wasn't strictly necessary
really but it's okay he wants to prevent
any night jumps to e5 in fact you black
could have played this kind of move he
possibly didn't want to have this kind
of position where white brings the snide
225 but it's maybe not such a big deal
this kind of position still should
should be relatively equal I'm still f6
is not a not a mistake so it's perfectly
alright yeah 92 also quite logical the
ideas oops not this not within the rules
now of course night will be three to see
5 or possibly to a five so it's all very
logical what what white is doing in this
game you also see that kramnik had a
rather huge time advantage this is um
yeah understandable because his moves
are very very obvious what what is doing
well black is yeah also not under huge
pressure but he needs to be careful that
that he doesn't somehow play some
inaccurate move I'd really gets into
trouble so Bishop e6 exchanging nidm
yeah and in this position it is actually
a very critical in this position it
doesn't look like it but it is critical
and it's quite funny this is the exact
position that was shown during the live
broadcast of the tournament and the left
broadcast means that they have got video
coverage and dumb and grandmaster
commentator and the English commentary's
is done by
um i think is Ukrainian if you have
gained in me roshni chenko so very
strong Grandmaster rated above 2,600 Edo
and in this case he actually had a guest
commentator which is top woman player
and I'm Uzi choke and moody choke here
was asked by morose and Schanker what
she would play in this position and she
she's she suggested the move b6 which I
really looked at to my eye rather
strange I must admit because it looks
like it it weakens this porn on a 60 you
cannot move this look at at at any point
because it's simply always hanging and
said well what do we add suggestion but
in fact if you look at this position
somewhere closer you will actually find
that this is the only playable move
really if black wants to avoid to get
under really big pressure like actually
must play this move there is no no big
gammon the big alternative the thing is
what he did in the game let's show this
you play Luke c7 and now Kramnik played
Knight to e5 and this is actually a
pretty interesting move also when I
looked at the live broadcast only or
mostly thinking about about this move
because somehow this looks like an
inviting square I'm putting pressure on
all these pawns but 95 is simply the
stronger move because it puts such a big
pressure on c6 and not only on c6
there's also a second threat and the
threat is actually the farm more
problematic one I think it's night x b7
and yeah what should like do about this
move the problem is there is nothing he
can do it's simply after this move that
like s yeah I think basically lost Roxy
seven looks perfectly normal but he must
have overlooked some kind of technical
detail after nine
f5 we see what happens in the game you
play rope to c8 and there is nothing
better simply you are you have no no
other great moves you can play on let's
say queen 27 if you want just to put
something out on the board but here
white can can also just take it's just
the same something like this what has
the choice you can take here or i can
play whoopsie 7 and both are really
really ugly you don't want want to have
this kind of position with white you're
having the rook on the 7th rank which
has been severely weakened so it's
really am it's really it's clear over
after the smooth so we must have
miscalculated something one possible
point of a miscalculation we can see in
a couple of moves so Roxy 8 what the
plate Knight takes rook takes and queen
s XD certainly saw this one and now this
night is under under tech it cannot move
so black has only this move and here
before yeah this was the whole idea it's
it's a terrible cross pin on the C file
and against this again the squeem only
six yeah I played queen d sammy
biological unpinning the squeem at least
and maybe just a speculation he only
calculated be five in this position
which chronic didn't play if b5 this is
actually a position that isn't one
hundred percent clear let's say 97 it's
also very dangerous obviously we can see
this what because white can shock
capture here and he still has these
pawns so this is probably also very good
for white but it's not not immediately
winning the game what Kramnik played
queen b 6 was far stronger simply
attacking this rock on
sem and now really threatening b5 with
devastating effect this is this is
simply simply over now what what should
like do in the game he played queen back
to e8 we can we can look at other moves
let's say work v8 this is actually an
overly punished with this with this line
and yeah like simply has no moves this
this night is close to getting lost
let's say goes here really it gets it
gets really ugly really quickly and hear
their multiple moves you can can he play
re5 and kill this night also rookie
seven is also terrible threatening mate
and yeah black simply gets gets
destroyed him nothing nothing to do what
else let's say this move what can we can
take em and regains the queen with a
winning position so it's it's just the
case of deadly pins pin and win yeah
okay played Queenie 8b five and now
black has fun little trip night XD form
and yeah but we see that Kramnik has
calculated everything perfectly now took
on c7 check this check slide point here
King moves to the side Knight takes on
c1 this was the the last little idea
that black head but why just takes yeah
it is temporarily a piece down even but
the combination of be porn and the Queen
against the stranded night is simply too
strong white just place this move very
strong winning a tempo on the Queen
black cannot take it the porn simply
promotes after this so black needs to
need to move the Queen he went to d8 and
now simply this one not even bothering
to take the night you can simply promote
the beep on
yeah black has nothing like this one
shot Quincy 7 check here Queen a 7-yard
now the pawn just just promote aunty
Aronian resigned white gets a new queen
next move ya Yin so you can see with the
exchange variation there's the little
bit of poison and this basically one
move this looks is happening over in
this position um yeah it simply lost the
game amazingly so on as pointed out by
mu Z took in the broadcast black cosplay
b6 and after b6 it's a very very
slightly better for white but black has
still good chances to hold this I think
he would have a little bit of time to
consolidate his position we can look at
this briefly so not this move so p6 so
what should why do one possibility would
be to try to triple on the c4 let's say
here and then a black hand numb play
something like this Queen d7 Quincy two
of white rice this and then 97 the idea
being if white tries to enter on the
seventh you can also go here and this is
nothing like as I think about equal here
yeah also note that this would be six
pawn really made this night look a bit
silly because it simply has no no points
of entry now I think I have to be six it
it's very likely that Aronian would have
managed to to hold this position but
Luke c7 was really yeah a big mistake
out of a very in luckiest looking
position yeah just this little move
really lost the game yeah so nice win
year for for Chrome neck and it also
obviously was very important for the
team as we show gloss on boy too so they
made a tie at the end young thanks for
watching and done I'll be back very soon
with the
17 to catch up with with a coverage of
these simple Olympian